you
thanks
it's
sh
so
[Music]
should
sh
yeah
just
exactly it CLE
otherwise
straight
through we know our
place
Mar
okay
[Music]
you
yeah
[Music]
m
you
good
evening
bre
you
they're
already
I think we've reached capacity I don't
want to have any more in here no no
completely full upstairs as well yeah
but still not it's still quite this
there's 80 upstairs
yeah so we so in total we've got we've
got well we've got know we've actually
got that
150 even everyone this is the
development committee of R District
Council as I'm sure you're aware um we
had some housekeeping to go through
first of all so I'll read the emergency
evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will in the
public car park at the side of the Civic
Suite please do not delay your
evacuation to correct any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio
recorded I'd like to remind members of
the public that this is an official
council meeting and the item before us
or items before us will be debated
according to the usual Council rules
that apply to Council meetings to which
the public are
admitted members of the public are not
permitted to speak at this meeting
unless they previously registered to
speak with member
services in this way everyone present
will be able to hear the debate and
councilors will be able to make an
informed
decision item one is apologies for
absence um I believe we have apologies
from councilors Mr and Mrs Mason
are there any other
apologies councelor Jack Norman is
substituting
for Mrs
Len I see there are nonmembers attending
uh councelor
hook counselor Mrs ho
councelor Mr
Hoy coun Angela ha coun bar wils coun
staring
and sorry not
cdon sitting with
us item four um do any members have
interest to declare
Please Mr boy
uh yes CH I've been advised that both
our and C have disclos of all pecuniary
interest and that we can speak and wait
and be in ch what people speak but prior
to the debate on each item that's item
five and item six we have to leave the
chamber for the
debate we will call you back or you may
actually vote from the upstairs
presentation when the particular item is
finished and you may then
return
right item
five application number 16 of
b162 stroke F land at the junction of
hor Lane and H road
railing board members are Cil black and
open to
the chairman the site forms part of the
field to the Northwest side of the
junction between pdge Road and roor
lanee opposite the site are Residential
Properties fronting h Road and roor Lane
and a parade of
shops The Proposal is to construct a
roundabout Junction to replace the
existing many roundabout the majority of
construction Works would occur in the
field outside of the currently adopted
Highway with the new carriageway arms to
connect roora
plane just swing there and to hridge
Road some of the houses fronting hridge
Road including those on Chapman Court
would be access from a revised cway with
a turning head created
here there is a pedestrian Crossing and
bus stop located on hridge road you can
just see the bus stop near this lamp
first lamp post here um with a
pedestrian Crossing just further further
north um and the parade of shops um with
a service access um sweeping around that
corner the application does not seek to
remove either of these um the the bus
stop or The Pedestrian Crossing um and
would retain existing footways the
service road and parking serving the Hur
parade would also be
unaltered the site is used as raising
land and is bounded by a hedge whilst
the route is provided which is shown in
this in this photo here around the field
this is not this does not form a public
right of way foot path or brid way the
brid way in the vicinity of the site
stop short of the application site sorry
just to the north
here site is within the metal CH Green
Belt where some forms of development are
restricted however development to
provide local transport infrastructure
such as this can be considered
appropriate and this is the view held
here the works are intended to ease
congestion at the existing V roundabout
and improve local traffic flows in
connection with proposed housing
development in the
locality there is no h objection subject
to condition which is duly recommended a
section 106 legal agreement requiring to
delivery of the roundabout proposed is
recommended in relation to the proposed
housing development in hridge which is
the second item on the agenda this
evening the recommendation for this
roundabout chairman is one of approval
subject to section 106 and conditions
are set out in the report in addition to
the ethics County Council Highway
condition thank you um we have public
speakers uh for this item um councelor
Chris sanley of nor Parish Council Mr
Trevor dodkins face two planning the
applicants agent and Mr Brian maren
Carlton as an objector um if councelor
Chris Stanley would care to come forward
please all of the public speakers and
any members that subsequently wish to
speak um will be limited to 5 minutes um
which I will time and I'll give a an
indication with one minute to
go please
okay um speaking on behalf of RoR Parish
Council
um and we would like to ask RDC to
refuse this application as it is
considered to be too small and will
still cause congestion to the traffic in
BO L although this construction does not
come within the parish council area the
construction of this may give rise to
problems further back down Ro Lane we
already have a road design at the a1245
junction with ro blame or be it with
traffic lights
that works well in having a filter Lane
into Roth Lane itself this could be
adopted instead of the roundabout if
everyone knows of the junction that
you'll know what I'm talking
about um there are no dimensions on the
on the
drawing I raise show you the drawing um
how big the roundabout will be and that
this would have an effect on the
residents locally the information given
to traffic at peak times is wully
inadequate because of the amount of
traffic heading towards hoverd there
will still be a h up with this proposed
R the size of the rabar indicates
however that the H Arctic will have
maneuverability on the roundout however
buses and static lotes do not have an
Arctic
body and may not be able to negotiate
the roundout depending on its
sides the land around this area is well
known to
flood and at times after Heavy Rain it
causes a problem and this problem could
be affected with the how high the
roundabout is going to be from the
street level already and the properties
adjacent to the
Mand if the drainage is not put in
correctly and if it is inadequate there
could be problems to these properties
the exit and the entrance to the local
shops as you can see is not as open or
may not be as open as it is
already and it is too near the
roundabout for traffic to come out of
the shop
area so we would request that the
application be rejected on the grounds
of lack of information and alternative
options thank you
chair thank you if you Cas return to
your seat and with Mr Trevor dodkins at
phase two planning as the appli agent to
come to the Des
[Music]
pleas you also have 5 minutes and I'll
give you a call at 1 minute to
go thank you chair I only have a a few
brief points following the officer's
report which I think was very thorough
um firstly the application responds
directly to issue identified by local
people at two exhibitions held to
publicize the residential development
proposals which is second on the agenda
this evening and the application
provides a direct response to the
infrastructure requirements identified
at those um two public
events it is an improvement on the
scheme proposed by six County Council
highways and to the first scheme we
tabled last year where we listened to
comments for example by Council black
and residents in Mor Road who felt that
there was a cold attack at the end of m
road we that moving around that further
further to the
north this is meant redesigning the
junction arrangement to directly address
the concerns raised and as I say to
directly improve on the scheme that was
designed by
Cil the hridge residential scheme only
has a very minor impact on this Junction
therefore provision of a roundout is a
significant benefit and resolve resolves
an existing and a longstanding existing
problem the enhanced traffic CL that
will resol and relieving congestion is
recognized by County highways who have
given their full support to the works
and recognize the design goes further
than even they
intended unfortunately further
improvements to design through a
dedicated left hand turn from Lan is not
viable while s's County council did not
consider it to be necessary however we
there is scope that's been added to the
L so it could be added in the future if
it was
wanted with can clarify in response to
some comments that this roundabout is in
addition in addition to the W Street
Lane Junction improvements in the domain
scheme and the site access roundabout
both of which are included within the
scope of residential
proposals in respect of the permissive
briway that exist You' seen on your
addendum we've indicated our willingness
in principle to acknowledge this route
and to suggest an appropriately wordy
condition to address the line of the BR
and surfacing that
Tye in summary members should not
underestimate the significant steps
undertaken to secure a way forward
through these Junction improvements
we've not done as other developers do
and just throw a load of money at the S
Count Council highways Department we're
ping forward we're ping forward tangible
Improvement it's an improvement that
both the County Council and rer District
Council have fail to deliver over a
significant length of time this
application will deliver this proposed
infrastructure project and should be
considered to be a major enhancement to
the local Raad
infrastructure however it must also be
recognized that the current option that
we have over the land has been secured
for only a limited period of time and
would enev to be expire with delivery of
the scheme and the related residential
development would delay for any reason
thank
you thank you very much if you would
return to your seat please and would Mr
Brian mil cson obor
[Music]
please
you you will also have five minutes and
I'll give you a call one minute to
go thank you
chairman so is this how democracy works
the original proposal was passed malan's
Lane Farm outline planning application
now revised as a separate application
due to RDC failure to carry out
reconsultation on any amendments to
mation the council should ensure
proportionate consultation is undertaken
with statutory consulties and
surrounding occupiers will have an
interest in the original application and
which has an impact on their amenities
all in accordance with the protocols for
consultation on all material amendments
to an existing planning application how
does the RDC statement on the statement
of community involvement allow for
engagement and consultation with the
community yet the officer report states
that objections carry little weight
implying otherwise although the
development the highway Authority have
consulted to discuss the traffic
assessments this is the first time we
have seen it the original the
environmental agency had requested
further flal flood model but as usual we
are not worthy of consultation the rord
district council report presents the
roundabout as favorable but we object
for the following reasons Rec
qualification of this application has
not been carried out as the design is
stated as a proposed size access three
arm option malan's Farm homage which is
totally misleading as this area is in
Lover's Farm Roth Lane ra we are
astounded this application has been
validated this is the third design
change of this proposed Junction now
using more precious Green Belt land the
first design was estimated at million
second at 1 A2 million and now estimated
near 22 million including the additional
land required the financial arrangements
are of concern on one purchase of land
two construction costs three
responsibility for cost recovery the
financial implications to the
communities of RA hdge and Ro will have
a major impact the existing pedestrian
Crossings and bus stop opposer the
existing shops and the oneway access to
hambur parade are not shown when these
are in use it causes gridlock at the
existing roundabout the access to the
shop shown off R Lane has not been
properly assessed because when vehicles
are parked serving the shops there is
restricted width or two-way traffic this
access can only lead to the existing
garages at the rear of the shops making
this roundout larger will not reduce the
number of vehicles using it but it will
attract more traffic as work proceeds on
the surrounding future development in
hotley ra and
H and the volume of traffic passing
through hdge from as far as South End
additional pedestrian Crossings are
conspicuous by their absence at the
propos roundabout if provided this would
cause further traffic congestion with
health and safety being compromised the
application proposes surface water
connections to a sway but this the
location distances and volume
assessments are not indicated and states
that this will not cause an increase in
the flood risk elsewhere we question
that surface water from hro Hill the
proposed Junction and an existing 300 mm
pipe leading from the railway tracks in
fale Road fills the water course on each
side of h Road eventually leading to
watery Lane so increased blood water is
inevitable and no proposals to lessen
the impact of flood water the
application States no heteros exist on
the site but the boundary to L's Farm is
surrounded by a double line of existing
hros there is no statement to reinstate
Elsewhere on site large landscaped areas
are shown no proposals how these will be
maintained we await confirmation this
application is only for the proposed
Junction or also meant for
the sorry have minutos amendment to Lane
Road Junction as a mentioned in appendex
B the revised assessment which is still
out of date as it still shows the
previous revised Ru Lane Junction layout
suggests no huge on Lower Road between 8
and 9 whereas even their own photographs
show cues regularly back up past the
help sports and social club BBC L East
recently reported dangerous levels of
nitrous oxide caused by diesel fumes
being found in and around the r area we
feel that with all these proposed
developments toking some 2,000 fings
with a population increase of 8,000
together with the corresponding traffic
movements will generate more congestion
causing greater problems and we are not
aware of the first bus company being
consulted on traffic assessment and bus
SS thank you Mr chairman thank
[Applause]
you right um I have an indication that
counselor Mr Hoy wishes to speak uh are
there any other non members that wish to
speak
also
sorry is that later that's later
yes right thank you chairman um I think
there's no doubt that everyone agrees
that something needs to be done at this
Junction I um joined the local Highway
panel in
2013 Under This Junction was being
discussed then and had been discussed in
previous years I'm sure counil back
every on how has been going on um within
that local Highway panel there were
suggestions around roundabouts
and one of the suggestions what it was
that it did need a dedicated leftand
filter name on ToBD Road and I believe
that that's still the
casee
um there the um judgment for the
developer or the acent re um in in what
he just said just now did say that the
increase is in traffic from the whole
development will be insignificant the S6
Highway seem to disagree because they
are saying that they would expect most
of it to most of the increasing traffic
to use um Roth Lane and they and I think
the report from the developers
themselves I do not have it in front of
me to hand suggesting something in the
region of 238 vehicle movements around
that area in the morning and I think
there were slightly more in the evening
so I don't think that's
insignificant um I'll move on to
flooding now there there is an issue
with flooding in that area and the
problem I foresee with this is that the
flood
water will will or may not be stored I'm
not sure where it's going to be stored
that's a little unclear to me however
it's going to be fed into the brook
along the side of H road that Brook
stream ditch carries water from that
catchment area around the railway
through that through that are are
through the golf club down to walry Lane
which is a flooding problem it's lower
than sea level and that's where the
problems occur so I think that needs a
bit a little bit more
thinking finally I'm just going to bring
up um the the highways S6 highways again
um in the original
documentation they suggested in a fact
they
stated that the roundabout should be
constructed prior to the commencement of
the HD development I did note in that
the office report for the original and
the original report that the officers
recommended um commencement prior to the
occupation of the 50th dwelling or unit
um they then changed the Dum the
officers with consultation the acent
suggested construction price the Hun
occupation but I would point out that
highways in their letter of the 18th of
March which is attached the addendum I
believe have said that it
should now be prior to the 50th
occupation that was waiting so I think
there's a lot of confusion out this I I
believe that
the the um development in hold of 30 is
pass would create an enormous amount of
traffic we've said 238 warning to and
roughly the same in the evening um the
actual construction traffic is often
ignored in these applications
construction traffic itself will create
traffic movements through this Junction
The Junction is already over Crow
an over capacity hence the reason why
the local highways panel looking at it
at least in 2013 and prior therefore I
believe that
any any construction of this roundabout
should take place prior to the
development
H thank
you thank you Council
H Council
indication
are there any other members that uh wish
wish to indicate councelor Smith and
councilor
hater okay thank you Mr chairman um
before I could begin can I ask the
offices to get ready on the screen
pages look for Pages 16 and
of the technical report from
Canon the
items thank you I that thank L um Mr
chairman I think this
application uh has produces
four overriding questions the first
which is a fairly straightforward one is
is roundabout suitable for thing to come
here or the traffic Improvement that to
come here yes it's an appropriate use of
the green belt improve the traffic
you've got horrendous problems with
traffic we need Improvement that's the
first question the second question is
will the proposal solve the problems of
course with 500 houses and by the
existing
situation I'll refer to that later I'm
not convinced
yet the third question is even if it
does solve the problems of the details
right for us to approve it tonight
details for example about equestrian use
without the impact on residents without
the impact on the shopping area Etc
details and I'll come back come back
back back to that as well and the fourth
point
is um we have to bear in mind the
consequences and the possible further
development of housing in this location
be prompted by the creation of this
round back with thir back further as
well so so I'll begin by saying yes we
need improvements it's quite clear we
need
improvements um if you as I mentioned
and looking at the uh we had on the
council website there is the the
technical note report from the
Consulting
Engineers um which of course makes out
this is all going to work it's
interesting on
page one of the pages inside here you
look at what will happen if we don't get
improved
um and what they say is if we don't get
improvements the driving on the L Lane
in the PM Peak between 5 and 6:00 in the
evening in
2014 you get a delay of 175 seconds on
average by
2019 with the extra growth in traffic
that that's creeping up to
201210 Second of
delays um then if you add in
the uh
2019 plus the 500 dwellings you get up
to
475 seconds of delay that's what we're
looking at there um and that shows what
an impact having the 500 dwellings will
do howage it will it will more than
double the delays so we need a
solution
um
the what what was we to is that although
the report talks about the free arms and
although the officers in the
presentation mention mention the bus
stop and mention pedestrian Crossing and
theing point
there the report here doesn't seem to
mention the bus stop or The Pedestrian
Crossing and I I'm not sure if they're
taking that into account when discussing
the
delays nor I'm a little bit concerned
about the the right hand terms that
involved if you look at the if you look
at the the plan you've got possible
right hand terms in and out out of mtim
road we got possible right hand turns
out of hamb
parade um I've got concerns there that
this the mod used might be too simple
and didn't look at the right hand turns
or the of the uh pedestrian Crossing of
a
bus in terms of details one minute thank
Mr CH I will continue um in terms of
details um I've got concerns about
question in use and about um screening
facing facing around about when get
screening right and having a condition
to be discussed discussed later about
stream is not enough now to summarize CH
if we could I I'll pause here and wait
to we can get um
page find the right
page of the Canon report it is Page
seven sorry page seven not 17 Page page
seven of can report and I'd like to
pause until that's
Str okay if you look to the bottom of
the page thank you to bottom of the page
um that's de that's what the developer
demonstrating that we bound about will
solve problems um producing delays in Ro
of only 10 seconds compared to
475 that up there at the moment however
if you scroll to you look at the the
buing above that's based also allowing
for um a proposed development to be land
up to 100 dwelling which is
significant sorry
Council I have allowed you 15 seconds
additional time
yes and I will continue uh I would I
would ask Mr I would ask this to be
deferred for further considerations in 5
minutes or whatever I can't deal with
all the conditions and all all the
problems who is Mr chairman
about residence on the screening
councelor Blake those are the conditions
of this meeting I'm sorry I can't change
them and oh yes you can Mr chairman oh
yes you
can I repeat those are the conditions
that have been set and I will not change
them but I will move toer Mr shman
further consideration and do you have a
second unless
no
right councelor Smith you also have five
minutes take time um can I just have
some clarity please we we've had mention
of the roundabout and when it should be
built in relation to the the other
development should that go go ahead um
is is this the appropriate agenda item
to discuss that or is it the next
one the delivery would be um in
connection with the heads of terms
attached to the um item SE um item six
and not this item okay right that's fine
thank you um secondly if I could come on
to the letter from mic County Council um
we we've got um
a condition there but we've also got
quite a line of of
informatives um a lot of conditions I'm
not so keen on informatives informatives
don't necessarily have to be complied
with yet when I I look through that
particular list of informatives there
are a number of um what I would consider
essential things there also things that
I've seen written as conditions quite
clearly um and I I'd like bit of clarity
that what what is there is as an
informative does does become conditioned
for instance the very last one for
details of s should be provided and
agreed have some clarity that please
yeah we can come back on that um OB we
reive this quite late late in terms of a
um a comment and any um the the issue of
informativ AR enforceable any of these
that can be taken into conditions will
be taken to conditions and especially as
you're quite right the last one about
the subs that will that will be that
will form a condition in terms of they
have to Prov Us full details to be to be
agreed and approved by the Lo planning
Authority in conjunction with this Cy
Council um so any of these that actually
um do actually form a condition which
aot lot of them actually do will be just
taken
forward
um in in this chamber we've um on
numerous occasions had issues with Essex
highways and that we don't like what
what they say but regrettably they are
the highways Authority they are the
people that have the final say and when
it comes to traffic there's normally as
many suggestions as there are people
about as to what is right and what is
wrong um and
although I I I I don't necessarily agree
with all that is put forward I feel that
on on this occasion um ESS highways
understanding the Dynamics supported by
detailed professional uh study of the um
environment have to be given uh Fair
credibility on on this occasion and I'll
be taking that very much in mind when I
when I come to my final
decision thank you councelor hater you
also have five minutes so I give you a
call at one minute uh Mr chairman
paragraph 56 of the report says the
roundabout will produce improvements in
Journey times who says so the applicant
uh and as Manley rice Davis once said he
would say that wouldn't he uh there is
no once again Mr chairman there is no
independent assessment of this aspect
ESS County Council highways always steer
clear of the traffic situation with aor
Lane development and holbridge potential
development there will be potential
entally 2,000 to 3,000 more vehicles on
roris Lane hridge Road low road and Wy
Lane which are country roads now full to
overc
capacity will this round alleviate the
situation I doubt it thank
you thank
[Applause]
you are there any other members which
speak Council
War uh thank you chairman uh um I just
wanted a couple of uh points clarified
uh that have been mentioned um the first
one is actually the roundabout itself
and uh the Turning circles that are
going to be available for traffic um
that has come up come up a little bit of
clarity on whether as it was mentioned
buses would be able to go around there
how many vehicles would actually be able
to occupy that round about the one time
um can I have a some some clarity on
that one please and I've got one other
item as well should I follow on with
that or wait the
answer from the um information we got
from County Council they ra no issues
with regards to other Road users so
therefore comment on that the um they
the development meets the required
standards for that road so therefore
we've got no other evidence on that
point so I I assume that in the
knowledge that it is a bus route that uh
they would have taken that into
consideration that buses would actually
be able to access the roundabout in a
good way that I mean that's my that's
our position I mean basically they said
it require it complies with the
council's highway and transportation
development control policies um so
basically it would have met their
requirements to meet all traffic users
on that road so taking from that their
policy are respect correct
I um there was another point that was
bought up by um councelor Hoy U with
regard to uh the disparity in the two
concepts on uh when the actual
roundabout would start uh whether it's
the 50th occupation or the H 100th
occupation and um I feel inclined to
want to be supporting the 50th
occupation uh as that would give greater
Comfort I think to members and I think
to the public in general with regard so
that so there wouldn't be a dely um I
don't know how other members feel about
that but uh um I that's in this I
believe is it
not I mean as you already said to the
council previously it's fact that that's
a matter dealt with thehead of terms of
the um item
six
are there any other members wishing to
speak not at this
point in that case no motion has
been
coun five minutes I could call at one
minute to go chairman uh having listened
to my
colleagues I have got a concern with the
the building of the
infrastructure
uh before the Housing Development has
start
commenced I'm in disagreement that we
have to wait until 50 houses are are
built now with regards to the
infrastructure I'm still not
convinced that
the statistics which have been put
forward and compared with the ex
existing volume versus the estimated
volume has not been
compared uh corre I wouldn't say
correctly hasn't hasn't been shown by
highways I would like the officer to
uh advise me advise the uh
cabinet of the the process in which
highways have taken forward in comparing
existing traffic volume uh versus
the traffic traffic volumes when the
houses are
completed and uh in summary uh my my
first
point uh with regards to the
um the infrastructure I would like the
the infrastructure to be uh confirmed
before any housing has uh commenced
and
secondly uh how the statist highway
statistics have been formulated to uh uh
to confirm that the the existing
infastructure is
viable the um the comments we have
received from the high Authority
basically is as follows um the highway
authorities assess the support and
documentation associated with the
upgrade of existing roundabout at L Lane
Page Road to provide a three a standard
three arm roundabout the proposed
roundabout was designed to accommodate
existing traffic flows any background
growth in traffic flows and proposed
traffic from the two major developments
within the area namely West R and
holbridge
at at a required and agreed forecast
year of
2019 in addition a sensitivity
assessment has considered a plus 15E
forecast at 2004
2034 in accordance with the dmrb
requirements the proposed roundabout
modeling demonstrates considerable
Reserve capacity at the assessment year
forecast for 2019 and operates within
the operational capacity for
2034 that is all the comments that we've
got messes to council and as such that
would show that there is capacity within
this um roundabout to deal with the
current and future flows in the
area thank you um for the benefit of
council yanu and members of the public I
can assure you that it's the ESS County
Council Rochford District local highways
panel chairman um that the techniques
and Equipment available to uh the S6
County highways who do those surveys is
second to none and is a very it is a
very brave person that would query their
statistics on such
surveys
as there's been no uh motion uh or
Amendment uh I will move from the chair
that uh the recommendation of officers
is approved as published um would those
in favor please show Mr chairman I wish
to move some amendments to your your
proposal
right um first of all with regards
to the condition regarding screening the
wording just to uh involve the board
councils in that it is very important V
live right next door to this and I want
to make certain that they get the
best the best outcome in terms of
screening and Landscaping that they can
do um subject to highway safety is that
possible i' like to have
condition
could you repeat that well the in in
conditions condition
two the
recomendation um talks about
Landscaping um and talks about details
detail subm subm to local planning
Authority and I was just likely possible
I I think with before if the world
councils could be involved or consulted
with regard to the
screening yes the landscape
I personally see no problem with
that thank you the second condition I
have concerns
about
um the bridal way and the crossing the
road up there although the AR's agent
when he spoke did refer to that um
there's nothing in the technical report
from Canon about the briway or it about
the cost stop or
about I don't know maybe advis here I
would like some kind of
addition this could be looked at to try
and get the best possible outcome in
terms of safety for
uming speed increases you I've got
concerns a su condition or something we
could add in on
that
I have something
fot
um the um the Landscaping condition is
the condition that we deal with the on
within the application the additional
works we th that outside the application
site um and therefore we've had no
request from Essex H authority to
require any further um additions to the
either a 106 agreement to look at Works
outside or even a requirement went to do
section 278 works works within the
highway to deal with the additional
requirements for
um a question use therefore I would be
very nervous about looking at
that can in an Ideal World yes I would
like um for hor be Stak but we can't
demand back tonight my concerns are that
under the plan that the Katie showed
earlier you've got the you've got the
blind way coming down southwards stoping
and at that point horse riders often
cross the road but it's just to the
north of this application site and and
as the dend said the S BL Association
very concerned about I'm not certain how
we can deal with that I you to get more
traffic anyway if round about Works
traffic speed up which is good for
drivers could be dangerous for horse
riders I'm not certain what is the step
forward of that I would just like it not
to be forgotten and something to be
looked at to see not just completely
disregard what said is there something
we can do in that as just informative to
look at it with the applicant or
something like that something I'm
looking for something to
help thank
you C stto you have minutes can I make
suggestion outside the
site but perhaps this is an issue that
could be dealt with by the local Highway
P I think that's a very good suggestion
um orbe it that the as you are aware as
a as a member of that panel um the the
budget is severely limited these days
but it is something which could come
under that as an improvement
subsequently and uh I think might be
looked upon favorably by a number of
MERS I completely agree just we don't
think there's any way we can look at
techically slowing down traffic to allow
for the horses to at that point we might
look Crossing further further away from
the roundabout and that would be a
matter
out that something which could be put
forward by the parish
council and District members as
well right we have uh the um application
as amended um for the
Landscaping which I believe is been
accepted and seconded by Council cmore
um in which case would all those in
favor of approval on that basis please
indicate that is
approved if councelor Mr Mrs Hoy care to
return to the chamber
[Music]
watching upstairs
anywhere
all right we there on item six um which
is the um outline plan commission for
land between windir Avenue and L Ro Mion
Lane
hdge members are C's black otm
hail Mr and Mrs
o chairman this site is located at the
southwest of the existing buildt up
second of hridge the site is bounded by
windir Avenue to the north and Lower
Road to the South the application site
excludes residential property um in the
center of the site bounded by
Red this would remain as
existing the site is in use for grazing
and hay making divided into a number of
fields with a group uh of farm buildings
Cally
positioned the site slat downwards from
north to south and the southern boundary
is formed of Hedge with a number of
trees along the road here uh and there's
a group of TPO protected trees um just
north of the site along Wind
Avenue a public foot path bisect the
site The Proposal is for outline
planning permission with all matters
reserved apart from two accesses to the
site one on Lower Road to the South and
one off malan's Lan on the eastern
boundary the key matters for
determination in this application are
the principle of residential development
the Quantum of development proposed the
two access to this is to the site and
the acceptability of impacts in terms of
Highways flood risk
Etc the site is allocated for
residential development under policy Sr
6A and policy scr 6B with the whole
allocation indicated to provide 500
dwellings as can be seen from the
comparison of the site allocation plan
to the left hand side here um against
the application site the application
site does not cover the whole allocation
a parcel of land to the northwest corner
and a part of land to the southwest
corner is excluded from the application
in different
ownership as 500 dwellings are proposed
on the application site the allocation
as a whole May exceed 500 dwellings if
planning permission were granted in the
future for the other Parcels those other
Parcels however would be subject to
separate applications and decision
making
policy however accepts a degree of
flexibility in the quantum and this
approach has been accepted on other
allocated sites the site can accommodate
the 500 dwellings
proposed the development would access
onto Lower Road by means of a roundabout
which is shown in the first image here
just off off the highway line of the
existing Lower
Road this would be provided early in the
construction program and has has been
discussed tonight night um there's a
possibility of currently being proposed
prior to the 100th dwelling and maybe
some debate about prior to 50th um
occupation second vehicular access to
the site would upgrade the existing
access by malan's Lane which is on this
um lower image on the screen um and this
would involve slight widening of the
junction with Al Grove um and it
footways would provided either side of
the either side the um highway there is
no Highway objection to either of the
proposed
accesses to mitigate impact of the
proposed development on the highway
Network improvements would be required
to the junction of watery Lane and
hridge Road and Roth Lane and hridge
Road The Junction with watery Lane would
be provided with a ghost rightand turn
and a roundabout as seen in the image on
screen would be provided at Roth Lane
Corbridge
Road as has been discussed there is no
objection to to to this um proposal from
the county highways
Authority Landscaping layout scale
access and design are all matters for
determination at a later reserved matter
stage if outline permission were granted
a concept master plan which is showing
on screen now has been submitted and
this indicates how a detailed layout
might be worked up at a later date this
demonstrates that development Parcels
would be accompanied by areas of open
space Landscaping including playay space
this plan also indicates intention for
pedestrian pedestrian and cycle links in
addition to the vehicular accesses at
points to connect to the existing
residential development and this part of
the concept master plan um is
welcomed however there are several
concerns with the indicative layout of
development Parcels into strategic green
spaces and it's considered that
improvements could be made to achieve a
better integration and relationship of
proposed and existing development
particularly on on the Eastern edge here
where currently um existing property is
back on to Green Space which is quite
narrow um and then development would
front onto that the other area of
concern particularly is this western
boundary where it's considered that a
country a green Countryside Edge could
be better achieved without the spine
Road being right up against the
boundary it is recommended that this
concept master plan not form part of the
approved plan to enable a higher quality
scheme to be worked up at a reserve
matter
stage in the course of the application
the environment agency required further
modeling at beaches Brook and this has
been undertaken the environment agency
now raised no objection subject to
conditions satisfied that all the
residential development would lie within
flood zone one at the lowest risk of
flooding only that part of the site in
the southwest corner which is the here
on the screen um is subject to a high
higher risk of
flooding and no residential development
is proposed here an additional condition
is recommended which would prevent
residential development in this part of
the
site a sustainable Urban drainage
Network would be provided to deal with
surface water with a number of
attenuation ponds and swailes these are
indicatively shown here um and in this
area here and a Swale is shown North
South Essex County Council is the lead
local flood authority of the statutory
consulty on surface water and rais no
objection subject to conditions and
detailed um plans of that surface water
drainage would be required and agreed by
the local planning
Authority core strategy and allocation
plan policy sets out the infrastructure
expected from residential development at
this site allocation and the following
will be delivered as already mentioned
some local Highway capacity improvements
the roundabout at Roth Lane Junction
improvements at watery Lane residential
travel plan and travel packs to
encourage use of public transport a
contribution to provide improvements to
cycle Route
135 rideway provision and maintenance
within the site public open space and
place based delivery and maintenance
within the site Youth and Community
facility will be provided by means of a
skate park and a health care
contribution of some £64,000 would be
delivered 35% of housing will be
delivered in line with policy
requirements and the sustainable Urban
drainage network will be required to be
provided and maintained in
perpetuity a £70,000 contribution would
be would be delivered to upgrade the
existing playing pitches in pool's Lane
and an education contribution of some
2.2 million would also be
delivered applications to plan
permission must be determined in
accordance with the adopted development
plan unless all the material
considerations justify otherwise the
proposal would Accord with the
development plan as the land is
allocated for residential development
subject to the recommended conditions
and delivery of section 106
infrastructure The Proposal would Accord
with other policy considerations and
mitigate impact the recommendation is
one of approval subject to the section
106 and conditions as reported including
those referred to in the body of the
report text to be
added
thank you thank you um we have uh three
uh public speakers uh on this item
counselor Miss Angelina marot of hridge
Paris Council in objection Mr Trevor
dokins phase two planing the applicant
agent and the right honorable Mr Mark
franois MP is an
objector um would uh councelor maritt
please step forward
as as before you'll have five minutes
I'll give you call at one go thank you
how which parish council unan objects to
this application which does not address
the problems we had FL infrastructure
both locally and FAL field the fact that
sudden significant growth in population
would have our perish especially with
regards to Education Health Care and
Community cohesion the applicants are
giving War line equal importance with ro
line for access to the west and we
consider it a rat run that is
overused this road already has issues
with heavy Vehicles which we fear would
be worsened by significant Road changes
to accommodate the extra vehicles that
another 500 homes agreen everyone who is
familiar with the district knows how
welln forry Lane is as it does not take
much for the road to flood causing a
great deal of disruption locally and in
turn has a knock on effect further a
field everyone who uses these roads
would have noticed during the three
months that the bridge was being
upgraded the impact it had on the local
infrastructure further a field there
needs to be Improvement to the main
roads and Junctions that service our
district including Fair gra interchange
of the
a127 and the
a1245 no one in this room can forget the
effect of the fire at melin's Farm had
on the local infrastructure it took me
along with other residents over two
hours to get from hridge to Wickford and
just last week an accident near to the
the carpent roundabout caused a a delay
of 40 minutes bearing in mind that this
development is not in isolation and a
similar size development is being
proposed to the north of London Road
which has now gone through this will
also have a heavy impact upon rur flame
and the surrounding areas it also needs
to be said that the traffic survey that
was provided with the initial
application was over 5 years old and and
that was a year ago so unless we've had
a fresh one that's six years old now we
feel that it does not give significant
information of the current status of the
traffic movement on our roads we are
greatly concerned about the impact this
development will have on education and
health provision our secondary schools
Fitz W Mark and slain Park are popular
and open
overprescribed the planning statement
2.16 states that there will be a deficit
of places and that I have as I've just
said with regard to the infrastructure
this application is not in isolation
the people moving into the north London
roow development and this proposed
development will want their children to
attend a good local secondary school too
Riverside Medical Center is currently
over subscribed I know that many
residents are experiencing difficulties
in getting an appointment even when they
do not request a particular doctor the
Dome surgery is also mentioned but this
is unlikely to be of any use to anyone
moving into the proposed developments as
it is only part time and has been under
threat of closure Sone Hospital which
provides a service not only to rord
District residents but also to Castle
point and sou B bars residents will
increasingly be under pressure with the
additional population these developments
and others will cause finally there is a
matter of this development stradling HD
and Roar Parish boundaries some other
homes in this devel velopment will use
HD facilities that will technically be
part of War of Parish we feel that these
affected residents will not fully be
part of the hbd community they will not
directly receive our newsletters Parish
information invites Etc and they will
have to contact Ro for services and
representation one minute thank you we
believe that this would create a vision
cause confusion and not Comm Community
cohesion HD Parish Council objects to
this application due to the issues
stated above and detailed in our full
objection submission thank you
[Applause]
chairman if Mr Trevor donkins would step
forward please phase two planning as the
Africans
AG
you will also have five minutes and I'll
give you a call at one
minut thank you chair as with the last
application uh the officer's report was
very thorough and I only have a few
comments um we live in a development
plan L system which is government policy
and this application follow some five
years of the council's core strategy and
site allocations uh development plan
documents um in terms of preparation and
consideration these were tested by two
government inspectors who have endorsed
the application of this site that high
court challenge against the site
application document has been
rejected the details of this application
meet the requirements of the concept
statement within the S location's dpd
indeed The Proposal goes further with
the provision of 6.2 hectares of public
open space within the site which is
actually in excess of 2.12 hects over
what's in the council's concept St
application um we're also beneficial
Highway works that more of them address
the impacts uh identified in the
transport
assessment the development will
contribute to a range of improved Sports
and recreational facilities including
existing pitch improvements ska par and
C L linkages
as there's been discussion about
integrating with uh the existing
settlement that something that we
discussed at the two exhibitions that we
held uh and we've looked at that uh
firstly uh we're proposing improvements
to existing plane facilities to
encourage use by new and existing
residents rather than just providing
them on our own site uh there will be
foot part and Cycle Way linkages and
we've also removed the Reta ele element
from the scheme that was in the concept
statement in inations document because
we feel that we don't want oursite to
provide its own retail facilities we
want our resid to use theage retail
facilities providing a sign significant
economic benefit to local
businesses we agree entirely with Ry
Town Council that the focus transport
improvements should be to ro Lane and
not watery Lane hence the scheme of
works that's proposed and now approved
this will deliver significant
improvements over and beyond that
necessary to mitigate the development
which is all we have to do as other
developers have done in the past um
however it's recognized that the
delivery SE Works rather than as I said
before just provideing funds will be
encumbered if it were not for this
development we spent the last 6 months
providing additional information to the
environment agency on flood risk a very
detailed level and as you heard there's
no objection from them on flood grounds
the scheme provides affordable housing
provision and a mix of uh Market
dwellings that reflect policy
requirements and will directly meet
housing requirements identify through
the course strategy I will just touch on
um infrastructure there's been
discussion about whether it's the r
should happen after 50 houses no houses
or 100
houses the County Council suggested 50
houses we're suggesting 100 houses
purely for de development economics if
we if if we're made to provide the RAB
before any houses are built there'll be
no pum priming no funds generated from
the
development I said at the beginning of
this meeting 50 50 houses would mean
sacrificing another benefit elsewhere We
Believe 100 houses will enable the r and
all the other benefits that be provided
and that's in the
inici the design of the development as
you've seen has embraced the concepts
identified through the council's design
policies and obviously at the detailed
stage that can be improved as mentioned
by officers in summary the site has been
identified as a strategic housing
allocation in the ad the Accord strategy
and this proposal delivers the council
strategy for the district the
development oford is f with the details
established by the allocations plan
which is the council's document
exceeding the requirements in a number
of significant respects thank
you thank you you turn that to the one
minute thank
you our third speaker is the right
honorable Mr Mark F MP as an
obor sure I'm sure you're aware of the
procedure now I think I've got the
H are you ready I am than good evening
Mr chairman council's ladies and
gentlemen I must begin by confirming
that I'm speaking this evening in my
capacity as the local Member of
Parliament for radi at lickford and not
as a minister of the department for
communities and local governments I wish
to concentrate on three areas of concern
relating to this application highways
issues fund risks and doubts about the
enforceability of the section 106
agreement which is crucial as that helps
pay for the
infrastructure one highways I'm
concerned that when this application was
first being produced it was based on a
traffic assessment that was already 5
years out of date I'm also wor that the
developer is seeking to reduce their
original contribution of around 1.75
million to the roundabout it will cost
about2 million broadly to deliver it um
and I cite in evidence paragraph 511 of
the report on the previous item that
focused on the roundabout itself that
says that Countryside properties will
pay £250,000 from their housing
development of rora FL and it then says
and I quote the site for land west of
hrid should therefore deliver the
remaining balance of the cost and the
construction of the roundabout for the
highway authority to adopt on completion
on this basis the application for the
proposed roundabout Accords with policy
T1 to the council's adopted core
strategy but in the addendum to the
officer's report which came out
yesterday the revised officer
recommendation States and I quote again
office agree that there should be some
flexibility in the requirements for the
section 106 to ensure that the
application scheme is viable and
delivers the significant
infrastructure in other words the
developers AR proposing to pay for the
bulk of the roundabout so who is and our
friend for the developers forgot to
mention that didn't
he two flood risks this is an issue of
serious concern to my constituents
particularly those living adjacent to
the proposed site some of whom have
experiened raw sewage coming up to their
toilets during periods of heavy rainfall
the environment agency was sufficiently
concerned to query the original
proposals which still don't deal
adequately with the issue of what would
happen in the event of exceptionally
heavy rainfall that's highlighted in
some detail by the submission for the PD
residents Association which I want to
reference as evidence that which I won't
repeat again in detail here for reasons
of the time Li third the section 106
agreement the developer made numerous
Financial commitments to the proposed
section 106 agreement including around
1.75 million towards the new roundabout
2.2 million towards educational
provision
164,000 towards Primary Healthcare
facilities and 70,000 towards drainage
of the pools l Sports bues this
represents well over4 million of
contributions but the developer has
already begun backtracking on this
moreover as I understand it the
developer is an offshore company and
it's not clear they're fully committed
to the scheme if they are granted
outline planning permission tonight they
might seek to sell on the site but an
obviously increased value with the owner
perhaps arguing that they never
negotiated the section 106 agreement and
are not bound by its contents in other
words much of the money needed for very
necessary infrastructure May yet
disappear when all of this plays
out I'm very
concerned particularly by the last
one in summary the proposed application
is based on a traffic survey which is
over 5 years old and it does not
adequately address the flood aspects of
the screen crucially on the eve of the
committee the develop ER with apparent
officer consent has already begun
backtracking on the commitment to
provide the necessary infrastructure via
the section 106 agreement a problem
which would only be exacerbated if they
were to sell the site on with planing
permission granted by the committee
tonight given the history of all of this
and it's actually been going on for
seven years not five I believe the
committee should not pass this
application unless the details of the
section 106 agreement have been f L
nailed down which is quite obviously
quite evidently not the
case in short the infrastructure money
to accompany the development simply is
not there you don't know who's going to
pay for the roundabout we are so because
the money is not there because the
infrastructure which everybody knows we
need is not guaranteed to be provided
don't pass
[Applause]
this
thank
you um I have an indication that both
councelor M and Mrs Hoy wish to
speak and also I believe councelor Mrs
H you have five minutes as before thanks
chairman first of all I'd like to than
thank thank members of the public for
attending and for taking part in the
process and for the massive response you
have made to this process I did ask for
a last large venue to be used but it was
for
years I will now deal with the
applicant traffic is a problem now and
will be worth if this application goes
ahead it totally fails to deal with waly
Lan as required by the core strategy and
the local
and suggesting that a few signs will do
no a few road signs will not do and we
know
that the course strategy requires
improvements for wry day including the
raising of the road
bed the application does not deal with
this at all in fact the application
tries to ignore wry Lane by saying
traffic should be encouraged to use raar
of Lane
well that would not
happen last year a survey was carried
out by the local Highway
panel councelor ke husand requested it
to see that that What proportion of
traffic going through hridge cuts down
watery
Lane will fully a third do so a very
high figure but a figure not recognized
in the report due to the failure of the
applicant undertak a traffic
survey next Public public
spaces the allocations document requires
a minimum of 3.6 hectares of public
natural semi- rural green space
accessible from
s68 and
s6b this does not Pride that
space the the proposals include verges
and two me shps of land around the edge
of the site to come up with the figure
in this report the allocations document
referred to a field sized area which is
on its own provided the space it cannot
include football pictures Etc it must
stand on its own as a complete area
therefore the application does not
demonstrate that the public open space
can be provided together with a Quantum
of development proposed in accordance
with the allocations document and should
be refused on this
basis community community procedures are
also missing with funds only suggested
to build a second skate park in Hy
surely it will be better to upgrade the
current one and have different
provisions on this site young people
have not been asked or consulted on this
which I guess is why they have come up
with the B stand of
suggestions no Community facilities are
provided despite being required in the
allocations document
why yes there is a community center in
hridge already but with extra people
more facilities are needed either extra
ones at or at the very least money given
to upgrade the existing one this is a
port application it fails to it fails to
listen to Residents and also ignores the
council's own allocations document as a
council we must we must not pass
application but do not meet our
standards this one does not and should
be refused thank
[Applause]
you C Mr Ho thank you
CH not understand I think um I can't
react much to um the comments made by um
councilor Meritt and Mark FR far but I I
would try um perhaps in a bit more
detail obviously some of the points I'm
about to raise have I believe already
been made how there there are important
points I must mention them again I only
have 5 minutes so I'll concentrate on
two aspects of the application which I
think clearly fail on material planning
grounds firstly I want to raise the
traffic assessment again this is
referred to from page 6.51 of the report
paragraph 4.23 refers to the extra
movements that would be produced by this
development and paragraph 4.24 refers to
the scoping of this document this
assessment is not fit for purpose the
developers are using data from a survey
carried out in 2010 and are backing up
backing it up with data from a separate
an unlink survey in
2013 undertaken in relation to the
So-Cal west of R application this 2013
survey was in relation to the Roth Lane
and does not include measurement data
for holbridge Road wry lane or Ferry
Road l Road comry Hill Junctions as
required in paragraph
4.25 the scoping documented in paragraph
4.2 2 4 would appear to refer to a
survey which was carried out on behalf
of the applicant in October November
2014 however the data from that
assessment has not been used in this
application and would in any case be
regarded as flawed as it was undertaken
the week before and then during half
term I do have correspondence with
highways on
that this application should therefore
be refused on the grounds that an
up-to-date traffic assessment has not
been undertaken as required by the 2007
guidance on transport assessment and the
PPG guidance on travel plans transport
assessments and statements in decision
making the 20110 assessment can in no
way be regarded as current and the 2013
assessment did not assess the road
Junctions required by Essex
highways secondly I want to talk to you
about the report from Natural England
Natural England is a statut conso team
and you can find their report starting
on page
6.36 this is going to be detailed sorry
in paragraph 3144 they start by saying
advise that further information is
required in order for the council to
conclude the proposed development is
unlikely to have a significant effect on
the Crouch and roach special protection
area and ramai which is internationally
important Wetland site in other words
the council needs more information to
show that the development would not have
a significant effect on these sites
naturally England are not happy
paragraph 3147 onwards details the
additional information required there's
a lot of it I can't detail it
here it includes this the consultation
does not include a habitat regulation
assessment in paragraph 3148 they have
gone on to say that the proposed is
likely to have a significant effect on
the Crouch and Road estri sbaa and Rams
our site and listen to this bit that
Therefore your Authority should not
Grant ping per at this stage an
appropriate assessment should now be
undertaken in order to assess the
implications of The Proposal
for some reason the officer report
starting on page 6.61 paragraph 4.67
onwards states that in paragraph 4.69
Natural England has confirmed that in
their view the proposed development
would not be likely to have significant
adverse effect on the designated area
sorry the designated
site consequently it is not necessary
for an appropriate assessment for the
purposes of the habitat regulations to
be carried out well I've just read
something different I think in paragraph
4.77 they then suggest that the site how
however does present only negligible
risk and this the condition should be
granted sorry a condition should the
planning permission be granted should be
attached to it um to justif um to allow
the applicant to prepare additional
information to inform the council in
making an appropriate assessment by
after we it's been passed tonight or not
one minute the office has in preparing
this report have therefore ignored or
downplayed the views of Natural England
on this who do not think the effect
would be negligible and that would have
a significant effect I remind the
applicants that the applicant has had
the councel that the applicant has had
well over a year to provide the
information and has not done so I
believe that this is an additional
reason for refusal that an appropriate
assessment has not been undertaken as
required by section 61 and 62 of the
habitats regulation and that the council
has not offered a satisfactory reason
for not doing so which St should the
council presented with an application
that in my opinion is very poor is taken
over a year to be heard and still does
not meet our standards despite
additional work the acant has done if
developments are to be built in our
district they must meet our standards
and needs as outlin in the allocations
document and the this does not do so and
ask you to make your decision decision
bearing that in mind thank you
[Applause]
than thank you
councelor thank you chairman i w going
to technicals about this
because everyone said that before me I
agree with all of it um however I would
like to express my personal opinion and
that of the majority of my fellow
Villages H is a small friendly community
and like many others I have dear family
and friends living here his close spirit
and feeling of belonging can only be
achieved within a village of his size
with an additional 500 new houses and a
large amount of unknown places this will
delute their existing community and lose
forever the current feeling of family
that people feel for each other in our
village we've been ignored by the bus
companies and County Council for years
with our request for extra buses
especially from the Dome the developer
will be pressured into pain for many
things but they will not be continually
subsidizing anything therefore you will
have to rely on the County Council to
improve services and as we can already
see even with the County Council res
building hridge they cannot even put a
base by the last Lower Road bus stop
instead passengers have to step out onto
a mighty ditch the doct surgery believe
they can expand doctor numbers but what
about facility there are only half a
dozen parking spaces many to forgot to
get into and a couple in a road
invariably people will be parking windir
Avenue causing a car Chan for those
local
residents the Riverside School in its
the primary school in its current setup
should be able to cope with the
expansion when I myself went to inside
school it was full with nearly 700
pupils so I'm sure the teaching staff
will expand to C the difference between
then and now is the secondary schools
currently hbd children have to fight for
a place in the over subscribed R schools
Swain park or Fitz W Mark we are told by
ESS County Council that Swain Park will
expand to cope they do possibly have
space if they build on their valuable
sports pictures but can you imagine what
such a huge establishment would be like
as a school limited Fields limited car
parking a nightmare drop off and
collection there is currently no school
bus provided some may be driven to
school by the parents adding to ro
congestion the rest of our children will
have to Walk The Busy 3 M plus Journey
obviously academies asies these schools
are our business and any expansion on
pupil numbers will increase their
revenue but our children are not
products to be churned out at the most
productive rate possible squashed in
like battery H the traffic on hridge
road will become unmanageable with more
and more houses being built east of Ry
and the
a127 traffic is forced to find a way
through holbridge the new proposed
roundabout will lead traffic but I fear
will encourage more people to cut
through hdge avoiding
railing along with hundreds of
additional cars from the new Rail and
Roar development this will cause immense
congestion at bed's Corner the traffic
will also back up onto an increasingly
overused a127 making this one of the
most miserable and dangerous gems in the
area I'm very much behind assisting
people in need of social housing the
core strategy States for developer
should Supply 35% of the housing these
calls however the kind of people need
social housing be they able boded or not
need more than anyone to be near the
infrastructure for their needs lower
paid key workers need to be within
economical reach of their job unemployed
need to be near new employment disabled
need to be near the services who can
give them the care they need in all of
these cases cdge is not the
solution regarding the Lower Road
roundabout it is my understanding that
the core strategy states that
infrastructure must be in place before
any development may start across the
district so not building roundabout
first surely goes against the strategy
policy my fellow colleagues and
counselors I implore you to refuse this
application and listen to the voices of
The Village which we love so
much thank
[Applause]
Youk thank you chair chairman if I may
please just briefly um as sorry before
you do I have to ask are there any other
me non-members who wish to speak this is
relevant before that okay um Mark place
of employment has been specifically
mentioned with regard to educational
contribution I believe that we're
talking about education provision
generally within this application rather
than specifically so I'd just like to
make it clear that I I I've understood
that but I don't feel that I've got a an
interest to declare thank you thank
you other members non-members wish to
speak thank you um councilor Miss and
Mrs ho have left the chamber which case
I throw it open to members to debate I
see councelor hater and councelor Smith
indicting so far
that's Mr chairman my major worry about
this development is the infrastructure
of the roads they are country roads now
full of vehicles beyond their
capacity watery Lane is subject to
flooding I recall recently an accident
caused the whole of the neighboring
roads to be gridlocked through ra hogley
and
hridge there is no mention of any
improvements to the Ferry Road lur Road
and comry Hill
roundabout this development along with
west of Ry will produce another 2,000 to
3,000 vehicles on the roads
there are another 138 potential homes in
the pipeline for London Road and we have
already development in gun close and
Theon
site all a cumulative effect on roads
and public
services Mr chairman the applican
produced a transport assessment six
years out of date Essex highways produce
nothing at all half of the
course why is there a provision that the
hambro hill roundabout should only be
completed by the 50th or 100th house
built surely infrastructure comes first
yes Mr chairman we clearly do not have
the infrastructure of
roads and the Public Services to cope
and that is leaving aside section 106
issues and potential
flooding in the case of roads and the
construction of a roundabout we
certainly do not have the required
infrastructure moreover Mr chairman we
are unluck and likely to get them given
that the UK national debt is 1.7
trillion and Rising thank
you C Smith thank you
chairman we get to applications like
this that we we don't like to see in
front of us because quite clearly the
vast majority of the residents in the
district would like to bring the
shutters up and to not have any more
development however we know that within
the role we take on as counselors
there's a lot of other factors that we
have to bear in mind and the fact is
that within our core strategy this
location as a as a place for development
has has been agreed and it has been
examined in a variety of different
places we're not looking at very much
detail at all here we're looking at
things in outline and uh I must admit
I'm finding it difficult to find
sufficient reason other than outside of
the things that have previously been
agreed in the core strategy to
provide reasons for objecting to this at
this moment in time how however there
are some things that are of
concern um we we we've had we've had
comment made about section 106
agreements as if they're uh based on a
handshake and a pat on the back between
uh people um the 6.1 rather clearly
states that a 106 is a legal agreement I
think if a 106 is is a legal agreement
and it is appropriately drawn up as
officers have demonstrated to us they've
got the ability to do on numerous
occasions in the past then we can have
some confidence in the conditions that
we will be able to impose within this
development however within the addendum
there is one particularly controversial
thing uh with regard to the 100th
occupation of the property before the
roundabout clearly the develop is a
business there's no argument about that
and and a business will need to make
money and somewhere along the line there
will be a threshold between them making
money and it not being worth the while I
don't think the mechanisms that we've
got here are aware should be used as a
way of forcing an application not to
happen just because we make it
uneconomic for them um however there's a
balance and I I think I I'm I'm inclined
to stick with the recommendation that
was that in the original report of f
50th occupation rather than the proposed
occupation but this is not an easy
decision but it's the start of a process
and I think there are many more uh
stages to go before we we get to the
Fine detail of of what is is proposed
and as the offic has outlined I I I do
agree that the the general concept for
the layout is something that could be
further improved but I don't see
sufficient difference between this and
the core strategy decision that has been
approved tested and properly examined so
um at this moment in time I'm I'm afraid
that my my view is that I will probably
reluctantly need to support what's
printed with the uh W with with a
variation of not accepting the 100th
development by the 50th
thank
you coun blackk you chairman I a
question regarding the quantum it's
explained to the officer's presentation
that this isn't the whole the site
that's coming up tonight most not all of
it in terms of the Quantum of possible
housing how much extra could we expect
in the
future
which plan might be best to Illustrated
but the the parcels of development that
um aren't within the application site
this
north um West corner and this pocket
down down here in the southwest corner
um it is an unknown quantity because we
don't have a layout plan that details
exactly how many dwellings could be
accommodated there um certainly in the
southwest corner there may well be
issues around flood risk given that the
environment agency already raised an
issue with regard to within the site
down there so I think we're talking
about this this parcel here
um I think um actually there has been um
and planning history um some refusals of
planning consents a number of years ago
um I think that's set out 14 houses and
18 houses um which were to be provided
in this kind of area here um but I'm
sorry I can't give you a okay thank you
actual figure thank
you last week counil Smith said this is
the start of the process actually it's
near the end of the process the process
began on September the 10th 2009 when
the council
um adopted the local plan um by voted 23
to4 which allocating talks about 500
houses in h and I was one of the four
who voted against and then in November
28th 2012 the council then voted to
allocate this specific site here for
housing been going for a long time and I
V you sit there as
well I share the concerns of other
members tonight on the public um the
concerns about space provided by Council
D Hoy um the inadequate Improvement to M
middle l i mean bearing in mind that in
November 28 2012 we were promised there
will be improvements to water relay I
couldn't be told what they were but we
were told there would be improvements
and the County Council said we don't
want to improve water and District said
oh
okay um you know I agree with the
comments of Mark fris and and Michael H
about the traffic assessment being
insufficient you know not done right we
should refuse it on those grounds Alone
um also looking for again M about the
the Crouch and roest the sras and the or
spas and the ramar
site I also see that the equestrians are
objecting the grounds that the policy
doesn't the application doesn't comply
policy R 6 regarding equestrian
news and one other important point when
Mark speaking he said he wasn't wearing
his ministerial hat he does have a
ministerial hat he's in the minister
that sets all these rules that we have
to follow and when he says he's not
confident about the the section 106
money I tend to agree with him um I'd
love to spot places him for a year or so
let him speaking the council tra here
about traffic and let me set the rules
in in White Hall but that's not going to
happen sorry Chris job's taken yeah for
now any for now um but
seriously the section 106 situation yes
is a contract if you look at one of
these slides that the offic put up right
at the start at the very bottom of it
was one of the conditions was that the
applicant would have to pay for any
independent assessment of the viability
of a SE 106 document agreement what it
says is if the applicant comes back or
if the applicant sells the land on to
somebody else and that application that
come come back and says hey we've looked
at it now and we don't think we can
afford it's not viable to do all these
improvements we've been told to do and
you're noding thank you sir um then we
we have to have a viability assessment
which I don't have to pay and if the if
the end of that viability
assessment the whoever scrutin says yeah
developers got a point but have to look
a million pounds of ucation yeah you
know get about that is what could happen
um especially if the developer sells the
land on the to another developer you
know that that's the worry that's the
worry um and I'm sorry I I'm going to be
consistent I'm vote against this one
[Applause]
tonight
that's the
step thank you chairman could I have the
drawing up on the screen of the
roundabout adjacent to the site um so we
can see it a little in a little bit more
detail please I'll pause while
that's is it it's the top one of the two
is it possible to expand on that at
all I'll take a second but can if
chair's happy for to pause and that stop
this
that's thank
you
let's
go
sorry that's Lely right I've got a
concern with with position of the
roundabout in relation to watery Lan
there uh I appreciate the um the corner
site that PL there is the one that
stopped the issue with regards to the
flooding when traffic is coming from
from hridge heading towards sry Lane
there's going to have to be a right turn
lane there I have concerned that that's
going to slow the traffic down uh around
the roundabout it would make more sense
to me if the roundabout was at the
junction of wry Lane I know it would
mean quite a bit of uh jiggering with
around the road within the thing but it
makes more sense to me rather than put
another Junction in there so that's
that's my biggest single concern there
and I'm not sure quite why they haven't
looked at that uh uh have done that they
actually did and this was theer the one
that she showed um K showed first was
the original version that was put
forward by the applicants and this was
actually preferred option put forward by
Essex County Council they preferred the
ghost the ghost right hand turn that
you've got here this is actually
preferred
option far far be for me to disagree
with as Cy Council but I'm inclined to
do so um couple of other points that I'd
like like to raise is one is quite a
minor point there was mention of a
bridal way uh in the site I was unclear
is there an existing briway or is it a
case of creating
one um within the head of terms of the
one6 agreement there will be a
requirement for a um for that to be
delivered within the site so there will
be requirements to them to provide a
with in the site so there's not one of
existing and just a little bit of a
clarification around the 106 agreements
if the site was to be sold on and
there's some concern about as to whether
the uh the 106 agreement would still be
valid if it wasn't we have to come back
before
us if the site is sold on well if the
planning if the site is sold on the
planning Mission will be sold with the
land and that would take along with the
106 agreement any variation to that 106
agreement that would then come back to
the to the Council of the Del
liberations so if there was a if the
site was sold on and you a developer
bought the site and was going to develop
the site out
and came to us with with a viability we
have that viability checked which is why
we've asked for contribution towards
that because we're not going to pay for
that if that then showed that there was
they they couldn't meet the requirements
we'd set out there' be some discussions
over what what what they could and
couldn't deliver and then we would bring
that back to committee for members to
them to to be to discuss so just to
clarify that g that would have to come
back to us if site so and to levate
council Black's concern there no if if
the site if site was so the agreement
goes with the land so that the agreement
is so it doesn't affect the agreement at
all the agreement is is a is is a legal
contract between the ACT between the
development in terms of the planning
consent and the legal entity of that
agreement so it be the variation if any
variation thank you just to be clear
chairman um any SE 6 is actually
registered on the local land charges
anyway and it comes of the land um as uh
Miss Mans any variation will come back
to members for
delation thank you chairman just a
question if I may um the the suggestion
that uh that the roundabout is subject
to 100 houses in line with what was said
earlier on I just reading the document
's County Council which we pinned some
of this recommendations around in this
second page on the addendum you talk
about 50 houses has there been some sort
of discretionary agreement between these
two parties because in the in the
document from M County Council talk if
be the occupation of 50 dwelling houses
and yet we're talking about 100 I just
bit of
clarity um I did go back to Mark LA on
that point um who's the Strategic um
engineer on that and there is no
technical reason why it has to be 50 or
100 if members are minded that we change
that figure that's the members put
forward in terms of a um an amendment to
this recommendation and the head of
terms that want
to
council thank you chairman um just
following on for that I would like to
put that forward then um as far as the
50 houses are concerned because I think
that is a concern uh with regard to uh
the veracity of that
roundabout I think that's
important seconded by Council cutmore
proposed by councel
Ward's no motion under the floor there's
no motion under the floor are there any
other members wishing to
speak C back yeah um on the
amendment the amendment to what no
motion has been moved yet
chair was
is proposed by Council Ward and seconded
by Council C an amendment to what motion
no
motion to to the um motion as as or
sorry the
recommendations as put forward by
officers okay there was no motion on the
floor by there there's no substantive
motion I stand to be corrected by our
legal officer but uh
by implication an amendment to to the um
to
anything in the officers report is is by
it's it's it's obvious a proposal U for
for acceptance of the officers uh report
as amended by that uh particular
Amendment proposed for the
50 thank you Mr chair in that I I will B
bu MO
so catching up with the transmission of
messages Cel
hater if I understand you correctly Mr
chairman on this that um if a section
106 agreement is in force and registered
as a local land charge if the developer
then
sales and another developer comes in and
says that while this particular section
106 agreement makes this development not
viable then that will come before this
committee and perhaps the section will
six condition will be jettison is that
correct the first issue is that the land
is sold and the land with the Planning
Commission and the 106 agement is then
passed on to the new landowner the new
land owner obviously then has to the
next stage will be looking at the
requirements of more6 that needs to be
met at at the key points most of the 106
requirements are to do with the post at
the point of development so you'd have
the reserve matters application coming
in first in terms of the the timings of
the 106 and any any viability checks
obviously a new developer might decide
to viability check the development at
the point in which he buys it but he
wouldn't know point of which he's got
what he's going to put on that land and
what value of the the housing so there
was what's called an open book
viabilities undertaken which he shows us
his figures we check those figures and
therefore he then would come to us and
say the site isn't viable it you know
the the cost of the land the building
and what you're requiring to you're
requiring to give to to give in terms of
of the 106 heads doesn't doesn't match
up we then come back to the council to
to members and we put that to you and
then we look at what whether or not we
agree with with his position or not and
then obviously we'd look at what would
then the variations of 106 agreement so
the issue would be the fact that
obviously it's what then is not but this
happens this happens it's not just
happen this one application this happens
this does happen and the point of view
is the fact that that's why we come back
to committee because we wouldn't do that
without any commit thank you thank
you thank you thank you Mr chairman yes
I will move up this point I second that
um I'll quote the grounds first of all
as stated by uh Mr M uh regarding the in
inadequate traffic assessment and out
ofate uh secondly as highlighted by
another member um lack of an assessment
regarding the impact on the Crouch and
Ro
est3 uh Spa Lamar as in paragraph
3148 um count
also clear with whether or not the open
space provision was in line with uh the
Elations document I like that clarifi as
possible for for the future thank
you thank
you counc hater I'll second I'll second
that Mr
chair do other members wish to speak to
the uh motion for
refusal
which case I will put it to the vote um
but with the comment as the Chairman's
prerogative that I think it might be a
edification for the right honorable
member um as regards to the need for
some changes to uh planning law and
probably a goodly overall revision that
might be a means of speeding uh
applications when wanted um and
enabling planning authorities to deal
with those that they don't want in a
more um s satisfactory way noted
chairman noted that with respect the law
requires developers to make
contributions for infrastructure too
that's already the law yeah I understand
I understand that thank you for your
comment um for those in favor of a
refusal please
show
it's
[Music]
refused those
against motion's lost the motion is
lost therefore return to the U motion
for uh approval with the amendment to um
50 houses as mentioned by councilors or
proposed by councilor board and cutmore
uh ask those to members to indicate for
those in favor of approval with that
Amendment
please that is
approved I like my vot against pleas
council is black and hater recording
their vote
against thank you everyone I believe
that is the end of the meeting meeting
Clos at 921 thank you for
attending